The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good morning,
everybody.
Let's go back to
where we were.
We were talking about abstract
data types and the notion of
object oriented programming.
And in particular, the role
of classes in all of that.
A lot of people think this
notion of object oriented
programming is a new notion.
In fact, it's not.
It's been around for probably
at least 35
years, maybe even longer.
But it's only been widely
practiced for maybe 15 years.
Even that to most of you will
seem like a long time.
It started in the mid 1970s
when people began to write
articles explaining this
advantage of the approach to
programming.
And at about the same time,
the language Smalltalk was
developed at Xerox Park and
CLU developed at MIT.
And they were the first
languages that, in an elegant
way, provided linguistic support
for this style of
programming.
But it didn't really take off
in the public until the
introduction of Java,
considerably later.
And Java was the first popular
language to support object
oriented programming.
After that there was C++, which
supports it in not a
very elegant but a usable way.
And today probably Python is the
fastest growing language
supporting object oriented
programming.
It's used widely, and
that's one of the
reasons we teach it here.
As I said, at the bottom of it
all, the most fundamental
notion is that of an
abstract data type.
And the idea is that we can
extend our programming
language by adding user
defined types.
And we'll shortly see why that's
such a useful thing.
And that these types can be used
just as easily as any of
the built in types.
Why do we call them abstract
data types rather than just
data types?
We do that because we are
essentially going to define
for each type an interface.
And essentially, what the
interface does is it explains
what the methods do.
What do I mean by
what they do?
What they do at the level of the
user, not how they do it.
That, of course, is the way
the built in types work.
It wasn't until Tuesday that you
understood how Python made
dicts do what they do.
Before then, I just explained,
that you could put in a key
and a value, and you could
look it up and do an
associative retrieval.
It was maybe not magic, but it
was wonderful that you could
do this and not have to bother
your heads with how it was
made to work.
And that was because we
provided, or the designers of
Python provided, an interface
that lets you use it.
We'll do the same thing with
the abstract data types.
The key idea here is one we've
talked about before and that's
a specification.
It is the specification of a
type, or of a function, or of
a method, that tells us
what that thing does.
And we'll now until the end of
the term try and maintain a
very clear distinction between
specifications and
implementations.
Let's look at an example.
So the example should
be familiar to you.
You will remember that on
Tuesday at the start of the
lecture, we looked at how we
could use hashing to implement
a set of integers.
And I explained to you that I
wasn't very happy with the
implementation because
of the way it
used this global variable.
Now we're going to see a much
more elegant approach.
So I'm going to define a new
abstract type called intSet.
I do that by writing the word,
class, followed by
the name of the class.
And then there's this funny
thing saying that it is a
subclass of objects.
Ignore that for now.
And I'm going to come
back to it later.
But fundamentally what it's
saying is that every instance
of intSet is an object.
That's not very interesting
because everything in Python
is an object.
So from an information theoretic
point of view,
there's no information here.
Later we'll see that we can use
this mechanism in a more
interesting way.
Now let's look at the methods.
So first I tell you a comment,
it's a set of integers.
Then I've got this funny
method called underbar
underbar init.
Whenever you see something with
an underbar underbar in
its name, it has a special
status in Python that lets us
do elegant things
with the syntax.
What will happen every time I
create a new object of type
intSet, the underbar underbar
init method, or function, of
the class will be executed
on that object.
What it will do, in this case,
is introduce two attributes of
the object.
The attributes are numBuckets
which is now replacing the
global variable we looked
at last time.
And I've arbitrarily
chosen 47.
And Vals.
This will be the hash table
itself containing the values.
And then, exactly as we did
on Tuesday, I'm going to
initialize the values so that
each element of this list is
now an empty list.
Now what's going on with this
funny notion of self.
Let's look at an example here.
I'm going to say s equals
intSet open close.
This will create a new intSet
object, execute the underbar
underbar init.
So if, for example, I print
self.numBuckets--
whoops, can't do that because
self is not defined in this
environment.
Self was a local variable to
underbar underbar init.
In fact, the formal parameter.
But I can write s.numBuckets,
and I'll see it's 47.
NumBuckets and Val are
now attributes of s.
Attributes of the instance
s of the class intSet.
And I [[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
what we would expect.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You didn't put any
object in between the
parentheses.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So that--
the question is well, it looks
like underbar underbar intSet
or underbar underbar init
has a formal parameter.
And I've given it no
corresponding actual parameter.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Let me finish.
So that's what it looks like.
And that's the magic
of this syntax.
It automatically passes
an implicit object,
or it creates one.
It's a very special role for
underbar underbar init.
Self is used to refer to the
object being created.
I'm going to come back in a
minute to discuss more fully
the concept of self and
how it's used here.
So just give me a minute
to get there.
The next thing we
see is hashE.
This is something we looked
at again on Tuesday.
It's a private function in this
case that I don't intend
to be used outside the class.
So if we think of the
specifications here, the
interface of the class, it
does not include hashE.
That's what private
means here.
This is a convention.
It's not enforced
by the language.
And unfortunately, as we'll see,
a lot of useful things
are not enforced by
the language.
But nevertheless, good
programmers follow the
conventions.
And we expect you guys to do so
as well because, of course,
you're good programmers.
So this doesn't do anything
very exciting.
It's just what we saw.
Insert is more interesting.
Let's look at what that does.
It apparently takes two
arguments, the formals named
self and E and inserts
E into self.vals.
However, if we go look at the
code that uses it in say
testone what you'll note is I'm
saying for i in range 40--
this is just like the testone
we looked at Tuesday.
I'm going to say
s.insert of i.
It looks like I'm calling insert
with only one argument,
but as we discussed last time,
this s before the dot is
actually the first argument
to the method insert.
And so it's getting two
arguments really.
And by convention, that implicit
first argument is
always called self in Python.
It's not enforced.
You could call it George if you
preferred, or Alice, or
whatever you like.
But if you do, you will confuse
the heck out of
anybody who ever reads your
code, including any
TA you ask for help.
So please do use self.
It's just a name.
It has nothing to do with
what a philosopher, or a
psychologist, or an ethicist
might think as the concept of
self, this wonderful
elevated concept.
It's none of those.
It's just a name.
But stick to using that name.
So if we go back, I can insert
a bunch of things.
I'm going to then print s.
That's kind of interesting.
UnderBar underbar STR, underbar
underbar is one of
those special names as well.
The code is pretty simple.
All it is is returning a string
representation of the set.
And it could be anything
you want.
I chose sort of a conventional
way of denoting sets.
What's interesting
is that it gets
automatically called by print.
So when I write the command,
print s, in test one, the
Python interpreter is smart
enough to know oh, I better
take s, convert it to a string,
and then print it.
How does it know to convert
it to a string?
It automatically invokes the
underbar underbar STR method.
And then the other operation
is member, which again is
exactly what we looked
at before.
But you'll notice in this code
that uses intSets, I make no
reference to the data attributes
of the class
directly, or I shouldn't.
You'll notice that I wrote
evil next to s.vals.
Python will let me do
it, but I shouldn't.
Why shouldn't I do it?
Why am I saying this is evil?
Well, would you be happy if you
got a message saying IDLE
was changed.
Please download a new version
and the new version happened
to have a different
implementation of lists or dicts.
And it caused all of your
programs to stop working.
You would be pretty unhappy.
Now why won't that happen?
Because your programs don't
depend, in any way, on the way
in which people chose to
implement those built in types
because you programmed to the
specification of the types,
not to the implementation.
The specification of intSet
did not mention Vals or
numBuckets.
Therefore, as the implementer of
that class, I'm entitled to
go back and change it.
So I'm not going to use
a hash table at all.
I'm going to do something
else.
I'm going to use a red, black
tree, or some other fancy
implementation.
I'm allowed to do that.
And if I make that change, and
Vals disappears and numBuckets
disappears, your program should
continue to work so
long as I still meet
the specification.
The minute you go in and
directly access the variables
of the class, those attributes,
you have used
things that do not appear
in this specification.
And if I change the
implementation, your program
might break.
So you shouldn't do that.
Does that make sense
to everybody?
It's a very important concept.
The concept is known
as data hiding.
It is really the most important
development that
makes abstract data
types useful.
It gives them the same status
as the built in types.
The minute you choose to
ignore this, you do
so at your own peril.
Some programming languages, like
Java, provide a mechanism
to enforce data hiding.
The designers of Python, for
reasons I do not understand,
chose not to.
I think it is a flaw
in the language.
The things we're hiding are
the instance variable.
Those are the variables
associated with each instance
of the class.
We should also hide
class variables.
We haven't seen those yet,
and we'll see them later.
The instance variables, we get
a new copy of each time we
created a new instance
of the class, a new
intSet in this case.
The class variables
are associated
with the class itself.
And you get only one
copy of them.
Later on, we'll see an
example where class
variables are useful.
All right.
So let's run this just to
make sure it works.
It does what we would expect.
True/False.
And then you'll see
this nice string
representation of the set.
And then just to show you what
happens when you do the evil
thing, I printed as we did
last time the actual
list that came out.
Let's now look at a more
interesting example.
And the idea I want to convey
here is how we use classes and
abstract data types to
design programs.
So imagine that you're writing a
program to keep track of all
the students, faculty, and
maybe staff at MIT.
It's certainly possible to write
that program without
using any classes.
For each student, you might
give them a family name, a
given name, a home address,
years, grades, et cetera.
And you could do this with some
complicated combination
of lists and dictionaries.
But it wouldn't be
very elegant.
So what I want to do before
writing that program--
and I won't actually
write that program.
I'll just write some of the
classes we can use--
I want to pull back and
think about what
abstractions would be useful.
So this style of programming
in which you organize your
programs around abstract data
types says before we write the
code in detail, we think about
these types that would make it
easy to write the code.
So for example, if you were
a finance student, and you
wanted to write some code
dealing with markets, you
might want to have an
abstraction of a government
bond, and another abstraction
of an equity, and an
extraction of a call option.
Whatever you want it.
But you'd say I want to think at
that level of abstraction.
I don't want to think about
lists, and dicts, and floats.
I just want to think about
options, which have a strike
price, a date, and
things like that.
Similarly, as I'm working on
this database for MIT, I want
to think about abstractions
of students, and
faculty, and staff.
I'm also going to use what's
called inheritance to set up a
hierarchy of these.
And the reason I'm going to do
that is I want to be able to
share a code.
I know that there will be
certain similarities between
students and faculty.
Some differences too.
But I want to begin by saying
what's not different?
What's similar?
What's the same?
So that I only have to
implement it once and
get to reuse it.
So if I pull back and say is
there an abstraction that
covers the shared attributes of
students, and faculty, and
staff, I might say
it's a person.
They're all people.
And it's arguable whether every
faculty member is a
human being, but for
now let's pretend.
And so I'm going to start with
this abstraction person.
I'm going to import something
called DateTime.
I'll show you what we're doing
when we get there.
But it's like we've imported
math before.
This is a class somebody else
wrote that deals with dates
and time in a fairly
reasonable way.
So I'm going to import that
here into person.
Probably didn't need
to import it twice.
Maybe I'll just simplify it by
getting rid of this one.
UnderBar underbar init
here will create a
person with name 'Name'.
And you'll notice what I'm doing
here is introducing an
extra attribute lastName
-- self.lastName.
And that's because I just want
to make life easy for myself.
I figure I'll want to find
the last name frequently.
Let's once and for all get it
and put it in something.
And I'm going to initialize
birthday to none.
The next attribute, or the next
method, is get lastName.
I have that here because I
don't want users of this
abstraction to even know that
I have an attribute
self.lastname.
That's part of the
implementation.
And so I have this method
that fetches it.
And you'll see as you build
classes that you often have
things called get.
And those are typically methods
that return some
information about an instance
of the class.
You'll also frequently have set
methods, for example, set
birthday that gives values to
instances of the class.
More interestingly,
I have get age.
And that's using some of the
built in operations on
DateTime conveniently.
It allows me to subtract one
date from another and get a
number of days.
So this will allow me to return
somebody's age in days.
Then I've got another underbar
underbar method we
haven't seen yet.
lt stands for less than.
Not a big surprise.
And I'm going to use this to
order names, or order people.
Why am I using a special
operator rather than just
putting in the method
L-E-S-S-T-H. A-N?
E-N?
I'm doing that because I want
to be able to write things
like p1 less than
p2 in my code.
And Python will take that and
turn it into the underbar
underbar LT.
Better yet, if I have a list say
of person's, I can use the
built in sort operator on that
list, and it will be smart
enough to know when it's
comparing two people to do the
sort to use the underbar
underbar LT.
Very convenient kind of thing.
Let's look at an example.
Let's look at some code.
So I'm going to set me to John
Guttag, and him to Barack
Hussein Obama, her to Madonna.
And we'll print some things.
So I printed him, and I printed
him.getlastName.
I can now set some birthdays.
Let's look at this line.
How do you feel about
him.birthday equals 8/4/61?
We'll come back to it.
But I want you to
think about it.
And we see that Obama is--
well, we see their ages here.
Actually, we see that
Madonna is older.
She looks really old when you
look at that number of days,
doesn't it.
Maybe she is.
Now what's going
to happen here?
I messed up.
And I messed up because I went
in and directly accessed the
instance variable and assigned
it what I thought was a
reasonable representation
of a birthdate.
But I shouldn't have because
that's not even the
appropriate type.
It's a string rather than
something from DateTime.
So again, we see the impact of
my having done this evil thing
of violating the abstraction
boundary and stuck in there
try to directly access
an instance variable.
We can do some comparisons.
And what we see is that I'm
not less than Madonna.
I guess that's OK.
You with me so far?
I can make a list of these
things and print the list.
So it does a fairly nice job
calling the underbar underbar
STR operator.
And you'll note I had no trouble
throwing objects of
type person into the list.
No different than putting
ints, or floats,
or any of the built-ins.
So it all works nicely.
And then I can sort
it and print that.
And now the lists come out in a
different order because it's
using the underbar underbar LT
operator to sort the elements.
All of this is just by way of
showing you how convenient it
is to write code that uses
a data abstraction.
If we go back and look at the
code, we'll see that once
again person was a subclass
of object.
That's why we can do all
these things we've
been doing with it.
But now I'm going to start
using the hierarchy.
MIT people are special.
I hate to say that because
I know we have non-MIT
people in the room.
But MIT people are special.
Well here's at least
one of the special
attributes of MIT people.
They all have an ID.
So I'm now going to say
an MIT person is a
special subclass of person.
So it has all of the properties
of a person.
And the way we describe that is
it inherits the properties
of the super class.
And it adds a property.
We can now assign
an ID number.
And now we're going to see the
thing I promised to show you,
which is a class variable.
Next ID num is not associated
with an instance of MIT
person, but it's associated
with the class itself.
It's a class variable.
I can do that because classes
are themselves objects.
And the advantage of this is
every time I get a new
instance of this class, I
can assign a unique ID.
Similar to the way we were using
global variables earlier
in the term, typically once we
have classes, we'd stop using
global variables because we have
these class variables,
which can serve very much the
same purpose in many cases.
And so now every time I get a
new MIT person, I give them an
ID and then increment the ID
number so that the next person
will get a different one.
So I added a property, this ID
number property, which I find
by get ID num.
I've also overwritten an
existing property.
You'll note that I've changed
the definition of underbar
underbar LT.
So it's now saying we're going
to compare two people not on
the basis of their
names but on the
basis of their ID numbers.
So let's look at some
code that uses this.
Get rid of the other
code so it doesn't
clutter up the screen.
So we'll look at some
things here.
We'll get some MIT people
called p1, p2, and p3.
And we'll print their ID nums
by calling get ID num.
And you can see that Barbara
Beaver gets 0, and the first
Sue Wong gets 1, and the second
Sue Wong has ID 2.
I can create even a
third such person.
And now let's think about
what happens here.
I'm going to print whether or
not p1 is less than p2 and
whether or not p3
is less than p2.
What should we get
when we do this?
Somebody?
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: True and false.
PROFESSOR: I heard
a true false.
And indeed that's right because
it's comparing IDs.
Now, suppose I want
to compare names.
I could if I chose do this.
I could call person underbar
underbar LT.
And what this says
is don't use the
less than of the subclass.
Go up and use the super class
one to do the comparison.
So it's going up
and doing that.
I can do other things.
I can compare things
for equality.
Let me just rip through all of
these and see what we get.
Whoops.
Surprise!
Well, before we get
to that surprise--
and it's not actually
a surprise.
I shouldn't have
uncommented it.
Let's look at the other ones.
We can say is p1 equal to p4?
And we discover it's not.
That's good.
And we can say is
p4 less than p3?
That all works.
It's not.
But I can't say p3
less than p4.
And why can't I do that?
Why did I get an error message
when I did that?
Yes?
Someone wanted to answer that?
AUDIENCE: That's because you
mix [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Can you say
that more loudly?
AUDIENCE: She's a person,
not an MIT person.
So you didn't assign
her an ID number.
PROFESSOR: Exactly right.
The answer--
I hit somebody right
on the head.
Now there's going to be a
traumatic brain injury.
I'm going to get sued.
It's going to be messy.
Time to leave the country.
All right.
Because it looks at p3 less than
p4, looks at the first
argument, which is p3, and says
OK, what's the underbar
underbar LT associated
with p3?
It's the one associated
with an MIT person.
Let's go execute that.
And then it tries to retrieve
the ID number of p4, which is
not an MIT person, and it
gets an error message.
All right.
Nothing subtle.
It's the same kind of thing
we've seen all along when we
use type errors.
In this case it's called an
attribute error because we've
attempted to access an attribute
of an instance that
doesn't exist.
And so we could catch it.
It's raised an exception.
We could catch it as we looked
at Tuesday, but we're not
going to do that because it's
really a programming bug when
that happens.
OK, let's continue.
We were interested
in students.
So we're going to continue
our hierarchy here.
And now I'm going to introduce
a subclass of an MIT person
called an UG, short
for undergraduate.
Underbar underbar init is
going to call MIT person
underbar underbar init, which
will give the UG an ID number
and a name.
And it's going to introduce
yet another instance
attribute, or field,
called the year.
And so the year, initially,
is none.
Then I can set the year.
Though if I try and set it as
something greater than 5, I'm
going to raise an overflow
error called too many.
No undergraduate should be
a year greater than 5.
And I can get the year.
Let's look at what happens
when we do that.
So I'll have two UG's.
Both happen to be
named Jane Doe.
And then the same MIT
person as before.
Let's run this code and see--
well, what's going to happen?
What's going to happen
when I say print UG1?
The first thing it's going to do
is going to say is there an
underbar underbar STR
associated with UGs?
And the answer is no.
That's OK because I know an
UG is also an MIT person.
If I don't find it at the
lowest level class, I'll
bounce up and say all right, is
there an underbar underbar
STR associated with
an MIT person?
No.
That's OK.
I'll go up another level and
say, well, I know an MIT
person happens to be a person.
And then they'll say oh, good
there is an underbar underbar
STR associated with person.
So I'll use that one.
So it looks at the class.
If it doesn't find it, it
goes to the super class.
And it does that all the way
up until the end, where at
worst, it will use the built-in
thing for printing
objects because remember
everything is
a subclass of objects.
You don't want to do that.
You want to have something more
elegant than object at
location xe345, or whatever
if would have printed.
Then we'll do some
comparisons.
It will first look for the most
local and then work its
way up as needed.
OK?
Let's keep going.
We're going to introduce another
kind of person called
a graduate student.
And I'm going to write pass.
What that means is a G is an
MIT person with no special
properties, all the usual
properties of an MIT person.
Does not have a year because
graduate students could be
here more or less forever,
which goes like
this when I say that.
Why did I introduce the type
in the first place?
Because it lets me
do type checking.
I can now check whether or not a
person is a graduate student
because an instance of G will
have all of the properties of
an MIT person, but it will
have a different type.
It will be type G.
And so I can now ask the
question is the type of this
object a G. Or is it
an MIT person and
get a different answer.
So I can do this.
And if I go type of G1--
well, that's interesting.
It says classmain.G.
It's going to upset its class.
And the class is defined at the
outermost level, which is
called main.
And the classes name is G,
which is what we expect.
And so I could write something
like that.
Type of G1 equals equals
G. And I get True.
Ok.
So it's a handy thing
to be able to do.
And in fact, I'm now going to
bounce back to MIT person and
add another method to it.
And this happens all the time
when I'm programming that I go
define a class, think I'm done,
and then some time later
decide that it would be
convenient to add something
new, another method.
In this case, I'm now adding the
method is student, which
returns type of self equal equal
UG or type of self equal
equals G.
So this will let me distinguish
a student from
another kind of MIT person.
So for example, if I want
to have a course list--
another class, this is
a subclass of object.
You'll note I have an add
student method, which takes
self and who, maybe
it should be whom.
And it says, if not
who.isstudent raise type error
not a student.
So I'm getting some leverage
now out of this.
Now I wouldn't need to
necessarily do this.
I could have said if not type
of who equals G, or type of
who equals UG.
But I chose not to.
The reason I chose not to is
looking ahead, I might want to
add some other students.
I might want to add special
student, for example.
Or I might want to add cross
registering student as
separate types.
Now, the nice thing is I don't
have to make a lot of changes.
I know there's exactly one place
in my code that defines
what it means to be
an MIT student.
I go back and I change
that method.
And even if I asked whether
somebody's a student in a 100
different places, I only
have to make one
change to fix my code.
So I'm getting some modularity
by associating the method with
the class MIT person rather
than every time
I need to use it.